la parole est à monsieur lionel luca
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
premier ministre voulait faire croire
que vous mener une politique de
réduction des dépenses de l'état et du
déficit budgétaire
il n'en est rien comme le révèle un
rapport accablant de la cour des comptes
qui démontre que le budget de 2014 s'est
aggravé son déficit s'est aggravé de
plus de 10 milliards par rapport à 2013
que la dette a été augmenté et que les
dépenses ont seulement été stabilisé
voulait faire croire que les maires sont
d'aussi mauvais gestionnaires que vous
il n'en est rien puisqu'ils votent eux
leur budget en équilibre
chaque année vous voulez faire croire
qu'ils doivent participer à la politique
de la supposée réduction des dépenses
que vous ne faites pas il n'en est rien
car il s'agit simplement d'un racket
vous aggravez chaque année la réduction
de leurs dotations vous aggravez chaque
année les prélèvements sous prétexte de
fonds de solidarité
le fonds de péréquation par exemple sous
prétexte de solidarité urbaine
ainsi les équipes nouvelles de 2014 qui
n'était en rien responsable de la
mauvaise gestion du logement pour les
années 2011 2013
non seulement se sont fait accabler ont
été mises en 40 mais surtout ont vu
leurs pénalités x 2 par 3 par câble par
cinq
parce que des préfets aux ordres devait
le faire pour des rentrées fiscales vous
créer de nouvelles dépenses pour les
communes avec les nouveaux rythmes
scolaires qui oblige à faire payer les
enfants de la république
quand allez vous respectez les maires
les cas monsieur andré vallini
secrétaire d'état chargé de la réforme
territoriale
merci monsieur le président monsieur le
député luca sur les deux derniers points
le logement et les rythmes scolaires
pour être précis le gouvernement avait
créé un fonds d'amorçage de 400 millions
d'euros qui n'étaient qu'un fonds
d'amorçage
au départ il a été pérennisé monsieur le
député il a été pérennisé deuxième
élément je vous confirme monsieur le
député que le gouvernement souhaite
mener une politique active du logement
social et souhaite aider les communes
qui s'engagent activement dans cette
politique de logement social d'où cette
aide nouvelle annoncée par le premier
ministre
200 millions d'euros pour les maires
bâtisseurs cela se traduira pas 2000
euros par logement créée dans les zones
tendues enfin plus généralement monsieur
le député je vous redis ce que je disais
à monsieur le député berrios il ya
quelques minutes
l'effort que nous demandons aux
collectivités locales est important
personne ne le conteste mais cet effort
s'inscrit dans un effort global de
réduction des déficits
la france ne peut pas continuer à vivre
avec une dette vertigineuse celle que
vous avez laissé et des déficits
abyssaux ce que vous avez laissé donc le
gouvernement redresse les comptes du
pays il demande aux communes d'y
contribuer à hauteur de ce qu'elle
représente dans la dépense publique
nationale sur 50 milliards d'euros
d'économies
nous demandons aux 11 milliards aux
collectivités locales c'est-à-dire 20%
le poids de leurs dépenses le poids de
leurs recettes dans l'ensemble des
dépenses du pays
c'est un effort important équitablement
réparti grâce à la péréquation et que
les mères dans leur immense majorité
comprennent très bien car moi aussi je
répète je rencontre chaque semaine des
dizaines de maires qui sont conscients
des responsabilités qui sont les leurs
merci monsieur le ministre